i ain't done  how old were you grace 15 and a half  you were 14 years old when gideon  charles first had sex with you  about you and that means i can find her  yet grace pretend to be jody he must  know something  gideon charles was killed yesterday  nearly was he  where were you between 5 p.m and 9 p.m  what if you don't knows what if i don't  what  i'm numb to myself and everyone around  me  seventeen months three weeks five days  jody will have her mum all that time i  just wanted to stop  you're feeling sorry i'm lighting  candles for my kid and she's not dead  this is not the end of it you only want  me in there so you can get jody i think  about my kid and still be a mate to you  can i you won't me and it weren't her so  i'll prove it to everyone  i'm all she's god's kid needs me  i'm not gonna stop i said i wouldn't and  i won't and it don't matter who  thinks i should or wants to call time i  can't i don't know how  i don't know where i'm going but i ain't  [Music]  lost  you